So, most retail traders skip this
lesson. They jump straight to
indicators, patterns, entry triggers,
and POCs. They go straight to AMT
framework, and then they wonder why
nothing works consistently. And the
answer is really simple. Every setup you
take sits in one of the questions the
market is always asking. Are we trending
or are we in a corrective structure?
What is the overall market structure? In
this video, I'm going to break down
these two regimes, show you how to
identify each one on any chart in
basically 10 seconds or less, and then
walk through why the same setup that
fires with high probabilities in one
regime gets shredded in another, okay?
Let's dive into this, okay? So, this is
all about market structure. And the
biggest, biggest, and most impactful
thing that can help you in your trading
is asking yourself one simple question.
Are we trending or are we corrective?
And that will give you a very, very good
framework and mindset to understand what
bias you should be taking and how much
risk you should be putting on each
trade.
So, if we look at the weekly, the number
one thing you always want to make sure
you're doing is understanding the higher
time frame bias. A lot of traders come
into our Discord in Orochi, and they're
asking why why did this not work out?
And it's a very simple question, right?
If your setup didn't work out, it's
because you probably didn't understand
the higher time frame structure from top
to bottom, right? You always want to
understand the monthly, the weekly, the
daily, and then the 4-hour, the 1-hour,
and the 15-minute time frame structure.
So, I'm going to walk you guys through
this here.
And I can show you exactly what this
looks like. So, this is the weekly,
right?
And basic market structure thinks that
this is a higher high, higher low,
right? And then a break of structure,
right, is when this higher high has been
obviously broken through, and it's a
continuation of this trend. So, this is
your higher high, your higher low. This
is the high that was put in. Now, you
have another higher high, right? And
then you continue higher high, higher
low. Here's your next higher high. And
then you have a bit of a corrective
phase. So, this is a trending structure.
This is a corrective structure where
your price is moving sideways. And in
this structure, you can clearly see that
we're having a difference in change on
the daily. So, when we zoom into the
daily, we are then having a bit of a
retrace where we have Here's our higher
high. We put in a technical higher low,
but when we come back up, this is a
lower high. So, there is a change of
character in this market structure. This
is typically called your CH
OCH, change of character.
And what this means is that the market
structure has now changed and shifted
locally because the weekly, right, is
still very bullish and has room for a
higher low to come down from its
previous higher low, right?
But on the daily, when we zoom in, you
can see the corrective nature where it
is a
higher high, higher low, lower high,
right? Because we didn't take the last
higher high.
Then it's a lower low because we took
out this low.
Then a lower high,
and then another lower low. And then the
trend resumes when we form another
higher high,
right? And then we take out that last
lower high, and then we form a higher
low,
higher high, higher low, and so on and
so on. So, you have to understand that
when you're in this environment, you
understand exactly what's happening on
the weekly because on the weekly, you're
still forming higher highs and higher
lows. This is still a higher low at the
end of the day, which is a pretty
significant retrace for BTC. That's 33%,
right? And then we have what?
Almost a 125%
run up to the highs.
Now, where this changes is on the weekly
here, right? On the weekly, BTC is still
bullish. We put in an all-time high at
126, but where this changes is we've had
our higher high,
then we had another higher low, right?
But then we had a failure to create
another high above this higher high. So,
this is a lower high, a lower low, a
lower high, and then now we made another
lower low. And then so on and so on. And
so why this is very important and why
I'm making this video for you guys is
when we finally get to the daily in here
in terms of the weekly, right? This is
your last lower high, lower low, and
then your previous lower high, right? So
if this is your last lower high,
price can still come up from this lower
low
to a significant price increase.
So we would say that we are actually
trending bullish, which we have been on
the daily here locally in this trend.
The weekly is bearish. However, the
daily, right, is still showing a lower
low, a lower high, a lower low, lower
high. But when we come into the 4-hour,
this tells a different story from this
lower low pivot because this
medium time frame trend is a higher
high, higher low, higher high, higher
low, higher high, higher low, higher
high, right? And now recently we've had
a shift in character, a higher high,
which is our swing high, and then we had
a higher low in the context of this low,
but this becomes a lower high and a
lower low, a lower high and a lower low.
So understanding the very simple basic
nature of this is is where you need to
really execute on and understand, right?
Because one, we talked about, well, this
is a trending market structure, but in
each market structure, right, this is
trending, so this is your lower lows and
lower highs, lower lows, lower highs.
But within some of these you have
corrective moves. And if this is a
corrective move back to the upside,
that's a corrective and you understand
that this is going to be a bit choppy,
just as this has been a corrective move
to the upside, this has been choppy,
right? So understanding back out on the
weekly, right, when we look at this is
clearly a trending move to the upside,
however, this is sideways retracement,
corrective behavior, lower lows and
lower highs that is still bearish but
bullish on the higher time frames,
right?
So you can have a weekly time frame to
super bullish, but you're getting a
retracement, which is healthy in
markets. Nothing goes up in a straight
line, right? Markets move in higher
highs, higher lows, right? You have What
you have is basic, simple market
structure, and understanding the market
structure on the weekly,
the daily, the 4-hour, the 1-hour gives
you a super simple and effective way to
assess the market structure, and then
you go into details like applying
auction market theory. Okay, well, if
we're trending correctness, where is the
overall auction and fair value of this
entire move, okay? And when we come down
into this, well, we say, "Well, this is
clearly bullish or bearish, excuse me.
This is bearish. We're still expecting
price to come higher eventually, but
this price action took how many days?
240 days to correct.
Now,
with that being said, in movements like
this, you don't want to be overly
bearish, but you still want to play the
right things. So, when you're having
your value area high, you have trending
market structure that is bearish on the
4-hour daily, right? Here's your last
high, your lower high, lower highs,
lower highs, right? You can very
effectively play this and even just in
terms of a very simple short setup,
short at the value area low, stops above
the last lower high,
and then you target the next lower low.
And in terms of this contact, it's very
effective because ultimately, you're
saying, "If this comes back above, well,
then we have a shift in market
structure, and I was wrong." Or you're
saying, "Well, I'm simply going to take
a short. I'm maybe I'm opening up a 3x
short. It's not a big position, but I'm
just giving a very relaxed trade because
my thesis is that we're going to print
another lower low and take out these
lows. So, if that's the case, we
shouldn't take out the last lower high
because
bearish market structure dictates that
the market will not take out the lower
highs,
right? The ones that count. Okay? This
is technically a lower high here. We
still took this high, but on the grand
scheme of the larger lower high content,
right? The daily time frame,
if the daily is trending bearish, those
daily lower highs are not going to be
swept. This is the 4-hour, so yes, we
can simply take out this, but we didn't
take out this daily lower high. And
that's where people get caught up
because they they they they think,
"Well, this is the next lower high, so
I'm going to place it here and give
myself a better R R."
But the smart ones traded back above the
lower high because price, yes, can
retrace almost to it, but it most
likely, the highest probability is it's
not going to take that out if it is a
trending bearish market structure,
and it's going to go and take the lower
low out. And that's the same thing over
here, okay? We retrace mostly almost to
the last lower high because now this is
a daily lower high,
and we target simply the next lower low.
And look how effective that is. That is
very simple.
And then it's a very relaxed way of
trading, okay? It's almost like trading
spot if you take a 2 to 5x simple short
using the value area high of this
overall value area range, right? So,
you're giving yourself a higher time
frame context, and obviously, you know,
you're going to want to be living in
these like 4-hour candles within
assessing on order flow in the 15-minute
chart a better entry. Yes, you could
have totally just taken a short set up
here, placed your stops above the highs.
Yes, you would have been underwater.
That wouldn't have been the best
execution. However,
it still worked in your favor. Or you
simply be patient and you wait for a
total breakdown again, right? Maybe you
took this, and then it kind of came down
to this level, stops break even, your
stop that break even, it came back up,
then you wait for the execution, the
entry back into this with stops above
that last lower high, right? There's so
many ways you can play this in your
favor.
Now, the one thing that I want to give
you guys as a takeaway for this, okay?
Now that we've kind of assessed the
4-hour going into the 1-hour and the
15-minute, there's a very, very clear
and effective way at understanding, "How
can I actually execute on a lower low
long
and a lower high short?"
And it's very simple, okay? If you are
identifying any levels, contacts, any
confluence that you get, right? You have
a monthly open down here, right? The one
thing that you're going to be doing when
you're down here is simply looking at
where is my value? Well, my value is
right in here, okay? So, here's your
value.
Now, you've created another lower low, a
lower low. You have your value. The
number one thing you're going to be
doing in AMT framework is looking for,
right? Acceptance back into value. Now
that we've swept the lows, let's take
out the highs. We swept the lows. Now
let's place a lower high in context of
the larger lower high. So, if we've
swept these major lows once, twice,
three times,
we can assume that we will have a bounce
back to the upside to take out this
ultimate high. Very simple market
structure.
All of this comes with exactly the last
5 minutes of what I just told you from
having a higher time frame understanding
of market structure.
Now,
with that being said, executing on the
15 minute is very simple. You have your
fixed range volume profile. You have
levels in mind that you can execute on.
You have your good friend the anchored
VWAP. And then all you're doing simply
is looking at the lower time frame shift
in market structure. So, over here, we
are clearly doing a lower low, a lower
high, a lower low, lower high cuz we
never took this high out, right? And
then a lower low. Now where it changes,
where you can execute on is the the very
small time frame shift of market
structure. And typically, right? This is
the golden pocket backtest, 618. This is
a lower low,
lower high, but now in context of this
low, this is a higher low. And then you
play the continuation setup and you can
target the absolute highs of the last
lower high move, which is basically 13%,
14%. They're very favorable very
favorable swing trade. Now, take this
same setup, this same blueprint over
here, okay? We're going to do the same
thing when we finally come up into those
highs.
So, this is our lower high.
And we're looking for the short. What do
we do? We take the fixed range volume
profile, and we look at the value that
we have.
We have a daily open here.
We have our good friend, the anchored
VWAP. And then we have the golden pocket
618 back test. This is where it should
click for you guys. It's the same thing
that we just did at the lower low with
the long. Now we're looking for the
short, and we have our ultimate high,
right?
This is a higher low, but in context to
this high, this is a lower high because
we come up, fail to take out this high.
This is a lower high. We then say,
"Okay, we have we SFP into the value
area. I'm going to take a short with the
stops above the ultimate high." And then
I'm going to move this and target what?
Well, I'm going to look for the hedge
play or the ultimate low, right? And
that's exactly what we got because we
got continuing retracements of a lower
high, lower low, lower high, lower low,
lower high, lower low. And look at that,
anchored VWAP from the swing high acting
as very, very nice resistance levels
coming up into it. You even have your
your point of control in this range
acting as resistance, right? Over here
and over here.
And then you have it as the value area
low, resistance, resistance. Pair that
with the anchored VWAP. Very nice. You
can also continue to play what? Our good
friend, the golden pocket, back at the
point of control, back at the value area
low. And what do we get? Well, we just
get very nice continuations of
rejections of lower highs. So, you have
confirmation of lower high structure,
and now congratulations, you've
basically done the same framework that
you did down here at the very top.
You've placed yourself in a favorable
swing trade, and now in terms of overall
structure, market structure, the only
thing you're really paying attention to
is what? Well, market structure, change
of character, and playing the range,
okay? If we simply look at again, now
that we've got ourselves into these nice
swing longs and shorts, we're in this
your long from the lows, short from the
highs.
What do you do next? Well, you simply
sit back, you look at the 4-hour, and
you say, well, this is a lower high. We
didn't take out the lower high. The
highest probability is we come down to
the lower low, right? And then we trade
this short back down. We set our long at
break even in this case. And if not,
well,
if we come back up, right? And maybe we
point a higher low in the overall
context. So, this is a lower low. We can
still do this, come down into what? Our
good friend, the 618.
Come down to the 618. That is then in
context of this low in the local range,
a higher low. So, this would be your
lower low, lower high, but then you
place a higher low,
and you come up into this level. All of
a sudden, you have medium-time frame
bullish market structure, and this long
you can continue to play up and up and
up and up and up. Your short gets
stopped out at break even. You hit a
good TP1 here, TP2 here. You juice that
short, and you're still hold on to the
long, and you're playing this up, so
you're still
making money on every side of the
market. So, using simple market
structure like this, you understand that
this long right here, right? Can still
come up into this level because why?
Well, when we come out to the daily and
the weekly, you understand that this is
a lower low, a lower high, a lower low,
and we can still do a lower high, right?
Because we have a lot of room to come
and retrace to as a lower high, and then
ultimately come down for a lower low, in
which then you look for the very big
short setup, right? Up at this level.
And what is the best place to do it at?
Well, you look at the 61866. So, it's
very simple,
very easy, and something that you need
to use all the time. Structure isn't the
sexy part of trading. It's the part that
makes everything else work. And if you
don't have this as the number one thing
that you're always assessing, you need
to go and re- relearn this before you
continue to do anything else that you're
doing.